In a quest for developers to remove memory leaks from their application
It tends to focus most energy on the most influential issues
However, one of the most frightening leaks often remains in the base of their non-observable code
My name is Colt McCannless, and one of the worst things
That can cause a leak in your Android application is the View object
For the most part, the views are simple small tools
Help us update your screen and display information
We generally do not think of them as a potential memory drain
Which I mean is true
The views themselves are not a leak problem much
Instead, it is what it refers to is what can cause a terrible leak situation
Remember that the Android garbage collection system can only recover objects
Which are no longer referred to by anything else within memory
Leaking is an object that is no longer needed
But there is still a reference to it somewhere in the system
This problem can follow when this object is pointing to other objects
These organisms refer to other objects
None of them can be removed in the entire chain of memory
Because of the existing references from that root leakage
So this is the problem
Views have a reference to the activity they created
Activities in turn also
Tend to refer to many internal objects and other memory elements
Therefore, the leak of the View object is a big problem
When a view causes a leak, the activity also refers to it
All other relevant data are included
Mainly, the whole activity stays in memory
Which can be a big problem in some cases
For example, when users turn their devices
An order change will be created, causing the current activity to be destroyed
A new copy is loaded in memory
But if a view is leaked from the first activity
The original activity can not be cleaned now
Therefore, it will only exist and consume memory
Which should be given to this new activity instead
Now, imagine if this happened and the user recycled his screen again
You will now suddenly get three separate cases of activity in memory
All of them are fighting for space
Therefore avoiding the leakage of View Objects should be a top priority for your memory management policy
To achieve this goal, here are some simple models that should be noticed
Number one, does not indicate views within concurrent inverse calls
This synchronized event may take place at some stage in the future where things are not perfect
I mean, in one case
This activity may be terminated before the reverse call is launched
But this offer will be retained in the activity as such
Until the asynchronous function is completed and you edit its reference to the view
In a worse situation, your reverse call may be executed after the View object has already been destroyed correctly
Thus removing the reference for an invalid object and causing your application to be disabled
Is not really important for performance
But you know that frequent crashes tend to appear poorly for users
However, secondly, do not refer to views of static objects
The issue here is that static objects still exist
Throughout the entire process that occupies your application
By the way, it is not the same age as the activity that declares the living object
As such, the existence of a static object indicates a view
Can cause problems when the activity is destroyed,
Let's say during a change of order
Because the view is still indicated by a static object
The still object then naturally refers to the activity as well
The view or activity will never be cleaned at any time
Because of the age of that object
Third, avoid putting views in groups that do not have memory cleaning patterns
For example, using a weak HashMap object to store views as values
The weak HashMaps stores the views as difficult references
You can eventually reach a bad spot at any time by doing something by destroying those views
This type of weak HashMap behavior has been called HashMap leak
Leak because HashMap is weak ...
Now, if you wonder where your memory is going
Be sure to check out the Customization Tracker tool within the Android Studio
If you see content from an activity that should not exist
You may need to take a hard look at your code
A strict scan of your code is all about what Android is doing
That's why you need to check out the rest of Android's performance patterns
Check out the Google+ community for other great tips
So keep calm, write your code, and always remember, performance is important.